نتحول مشاهدينا الى المؤتمر الصحفي
للمتحدث باسم حركه حماس اسامه حمدان في
بيروت ليعلم الله الذين امنوا ويتخذ منكم
شهداء والله لا يحب
الظالمين ابدا بالترحم على ارواح القاده
الشهداء
القائد الوطني الكبير الشهيد الشيخ صالح
العاروري نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي
للحركه وقائد الضفه الغربيه
كذلك والشهيد
القسامي سمير
فندي والشهيد
القسامي عزام الاقرع وهما من قاده
القسام والشهداء
المجاهدون الشهيد احمد حمود الشهيد محمد
الريس الشهيد محمود شاهين والشهيد
محمد
بشاشه هؤلاء الشهداء الذين ارتقوا اثر
غاره صهيونيه
غادره على مكتب للحركه في بيروت في
الضاحيه
الجنوبيه بعد مسيره حافله يرتقي هؤلاء
الشهداء مسيره حافله
بالعطاء سجنا وابعاده مقاومه و هادا ثباتا
ثم
ارتقاء الى عليين باذن الله سبحانه
وتعالى هؤلاء الشهداء هم من جمله شهداء
ابناء
شعبنا الذين يصمدون يجاهدون يقاومون هم
نموذج لجهاد الشعب
الفلسطيني في كل ساحه تواجد فيها شعبنا
وفي كل ساحه ا اقتضى الجهاد ان يتواجد
فيها
المقاومون نحن هنا نؤكد ان عمليه الاغتيال
الجبانه لن تكسر اراده المقاومه ولن تزعزع
ثقتنا بمشروعنا وبجهاز
فنحن ندرك ان هذا الطريق طريق ذات الشوكه
انما هو طريق فيه صبر
وتضحيه فيه ابتلاء ولكن عاقبته نصر وتحرير
وعوده باذن الله في هذه
العمليه يؤكد العدو مره اخرى انه لا يحترم
قانونا ولا
مواثيق ولا يعترف بامن ولا استقرار اي
دوله في المنطقه ويؤكد العدو هنا كذلك انه
لا يعرف الا لغه واحده هي لغه القوه
الوحيده القادره على لجم عدوانه لان هذا
العدوان لا يعيده الى الوراء الا صمود
المقاومين
وتضحياتهم ونؤكد
كذلك اننا باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى سندرك
ثارنا من هذا العدو ثارنا الحقيقي والكبير
ان يزول هذا الكيان عن الوجود ثارنا
الحقيقي والكبير ان نحرر قدسنا وارضنا وان
نستعيد كل ما اغتصب منا ثارنا الحقيقي
الكبير يوم ان يعود شعبنا الى ارضه ووطنه
الى مدنه وقراه ومزار التي اخرج منها عنوه
وقهرا منذ اكثر من
عاما ولكننا في سياق المواجهه سيفهم العدو
منا ردا يعظ منه ويدرك ان مثل هذه
الاعتداءات لن تخدم اهدافه بحال من
الاحوال وسات احدث في نقاط محدده وابدا
بالحديث عن مجازر هذا العدو النازي
الجديد نحن اليوم في اليوم
الال لحرب الاباده الجماعيه التي يشنها
هذا الاحتلال على ابناء شعبنا في قطاع غزه
وفي ضفتنا
الثائره وفي تلخيص سريع لحجم هذه المجازر
وليدرك الجميع طبيعتها لقد بلغ عدد
الشهداء حتى اللحظه
و722 شهيدا من بينهم 100 الا طفل و7000
امراه اما الجرحى فهم
و166 من الجرحى
والمصابين فيما بلغ عدد الشهداء في الضفه
الغربيه منذ السابع من اكتوبر
321 شهيدا منهم 111 طفلا للذين يقولون ان
هذا العدو
يميز اما اما النساء من الشهداء فكن
اربع وتجاوز عدد مفقودين في قطاع غزه تحت
الركام 7000
مفقود هذا يعني ان
4% من سكان قطاع غزه هم بين شهيد وجريح
ومفقود وحتى يفهم الجميع قيمه هذا الرقم
هذا يعني 13 مليون
و250 ال قتيل وجريح ومفقود في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عندما تتعرض لعدوان او
غزو من هذا النوع ان من يستسهل الارقام
عليه ان يدرك تماما اننا لا نعد شعبنا
ارقاما بل هم بشر لهم امالهم واحلامهم
طموحاتهم لهم ذكرياتهم ولهم هدف كبير ان
يتحرر
وطنهم اكثر من مليون و900 ال فلسطيني من
ابناء قطاع غزه مشردون من
بيوتهم لا ملجا لهم ولا ملجا امنه في اي
مكان من قطاع غزه على عكس ما يروج
الاحتلال وداعمه الامريكي وبعض الداعمين
الصغار هذا الاحتلال النازي دمر حتى
اللحظه
70% من المنشات المدنيه والبنى التحتيه في
قطاع غزه بغرض فرض التهجير القسري
على ابناء
شعبنا وقد خرج نتيجه هذا
التدمير 30 مستشفى من من خدمه
الفعليه
و53 مركزا صحيا تم تدميرها ولا تتوفر اي
مقومات للعمل الطبي في قطاع غزه اما
الاصابات البالغه التي تقتضي علاجا في
الخارج فقد بلغت 6000
اصابه سافر منها للعلاج 650 فقط حتى
اللحظه اننا نؤكد هنا ان
المطلوب ان يتم التعامل مع مصابينا
وجرحانا مع شهدائنا ومفقودين على انهم بشر
وليسوا مجرد ارقام ونحمل المسؤوليه هنا في
ذلك لكل المؤسسات الدوليه التي تتحدث عن
حقوق الانسان
وتتحدث عن عدم اصابه المدنيين في اي
معركه لقد طالت جرائم الاحتلال كذلك
الصحفيين في عمليات قتل متعمد وبلغ عدد
الصحفيين الذين ارتقوا حتى الساعه 109 من
الصحفيين اخرهم الشهيد حمزه الدحدوح نجل
الصحفي وائل الدحدوح
والصحفي الشهيد مصطفى ثريا والصحفي الشهيد
علي ابو عجوه ان هذه الجرائم المتتابعه في
استهدام الص في استهداف الصحفيين لا تعني
الا شيئا واحدا سقوط الروايه الصهيونيه
للعدوان ومحاوله هذا الكيان تكميم افواه
الحقيقه وقتلها قبل ان تصل الى الناس
لينفضوا مثل هذه الجرائم لن تمنع الحقيقه
من الوصول الى العالم الذي بات يرى هذا
الكيان رؤيه واضحه كيانا ارهابيا نازيا
قاتلا اما في جرائم حرق البيوت
والمنازل فقد تجاوز العدو حدود الفعل
النازي اذ بات يحرق البيوت والمنازل بما
فيها من المدنيين والابرياء الذين في
غالبهم هم من النساء والاطفال والمرضى
والعجزه ولعل اخر الامثله التي راها
العالم صباح اليوم مجزره عائله ابو علبه
في مخيم جباليا في الفلوجه التي ارتقى
فيها 80 شهيدا من النساء والاطفال قتلوا
دفعه واحده بقصف من الكيان
الصهيوني وتجاوز الامر كذلك الى جرائم
اقتحام البيوت واخراج الرجال والشباب منها
وقتلهم امام النساء والاطفال بعد تعريت من
ثيابهم ثم خطف الاطفال كذلك من الجرائم
المستجده التي بدا العالم يراها بوضوح اضف
الى ذلك جرائم تدمير المواقع الاثريه في
غزه في محاوله يائسه لطمس معالم الثقافه
والحضاره والتراث الفلسطيني حيث دمر اكثر
من 200 موقع اثري وتراثي من اصل
325 موقع مسجل في قطاع غزه كمواقع اثريه
وتراثيه بينها مساجد وكنائس ومدارس ومتاحف
ومنازل اثريه قديمه ومواقع
مختلفه هذه الجرائم الصهيونيه هي برسم هذا
العالم وهي برسم كل من يتكلم عن الحقوق
حقوق الانسان او حقوق
الشعوب اما المساله الثانيه فهي في المسار
الميداني فمنذ بدايه ال منذ بدايه هذا
العام 2024 والى اليوم وبعد انقضاء ثلاثه
اشهر لا تزال المقاومه متشبه بارضها تواصل
بعناد مقارعه الاحتلال ولا تزال الصواريخ
التي تعهد قاده الاحتلال بوقفها تنطلق كل
يوم لتصل الى قلب هذا الكيان ولتثبت من
جديد ان المقاومه تتحكم بكل قدره وقوه في
مسار المعركه ولديها في جعبتها الكثير اث
خانا في جيش العدو
واساءه لوجه اركان حربه وثارا لدماء
الشهداء وانتصارا للقدس
والاقصى العدو انسحب من المنطقه الشماليه
وبقي فقط في الاطراف الغربيه منها اقصى
غرب بيت
لاهيه وهو يتحدث هذا جيش الاحتلال يتحدث
عن دخول المرحله
الثالثه ويقول للقياده السياسيه انه قد
انهى عمليته العسكريه فماذا عن اليوم
التالي هذا الانسحاب ياتي في ظل وجود قوات
المقاومه في مواقعها وانا اؤكد هنا ان
قوات المقاومه بخير في اللواء الشمالي وفي
لواء غزه لقد قاتلت هذه القوات العدو
ودافعت عن ارضها حتى خرج الاحتلال دون ان
يظفر بتحقيق اي من الاهداف التي اراد فهو
لم يدمر هذه القوات ولم يدمر الحركه كما
وعد وهو لم يستخرج اسيرا واحدا من الاسرى
لدى
المقاومه الا ما قتل وما اخذه من جثث كقتل
وهو كذلك لم ولن يستطيع ان يهجر شعبنا عن
ارضه اما في المنطقه الجنوبيه في خان يونس
حيث تدور المعركه وفي المنط المقه الوسطى
فقد دفع العدو بقرابه فرقتين سبعه الويه
تقاتل في هذه المنطقه وحتى الان لم يتمكن
العدو من تحقيق اي انجاز على الارض بخصوص
الاهداف التي اعلن ونحن هنا نطمئن الجميع
انه سيخرج باذن الله من خانيونس كما خرج
من الشمال دون تحقيق اي من الاهداف التي
اعلن عنها في بدايه عدوانه على قطاع غزه
ولن يجد بدا من النزول على شروط المقاومه
ان اراد ان يستعيد الاسرى ان الازمه تستعر
اليوم داخل الكيان الصهيوني نتيجه واقع
الميدان فقد فشل في تحقيق اهدافه وبات كل
اعضاء حكومه العدوان يدركون عدم القدره
على تحقيق هذه الاهداف انه لا امل في ذلك
فالحكومة الذين ظلموا اي منقلب ينقلبون
اما في الضفه في ضفه القسام التي تتعرض
لعدوان همجي في مدن وقرى هذه الضفه واخرها
عدوانه في جينين فجر
اليوم فلازال المقاومون في الضفه ثابتون
ويوقعون الخسائر في جيش الاحتلال رغم عظيم
التضحيات لقد تبين ل العالمي حقيقه هذا
الجيش النازي الذي جرت المراهنه
عليه تبين انه لا يملك لا شرفا ولا اخلاقا
ولا مبادئ ولا عقيده قتاليه ولا هدف سوى
ممارسه المزيد من القتل والمجازر بحق
المدنيين والاطفال والنساء وان اسطورته
التي بنى عليها العالم قد تحطمت و انهارت
تماما امام بساله وقدره
المقاومه وكل محاولات ترميم صوره هذا
الجيش بعد السابع من تشرين اول اكتوبر
الماضي لم تنجح ولن تنجح باذن
الله ومشهد القياده السياسيه لهذه الحرب
حكومه نتنياهو بعد اكثر من 90 يوما من
العدوان هو مشهد متبك
ومضطرب
ومتاكليش
النقطه الثالثه التي ارغب الحديث عنها
تتعلق بعوده الحديث عن موضوع تهجير الشعب
الفلسطيني اذ بدا في الايام الاخيره تكرار
ممجوج لموضوع التهجير تحت عنوان ساذج
الهجره الطوعيه لسك كان قطاع غزه يردده
نتنياهو وبنك فير
وسموت وغيرهم من المتطرفين
النازيين ونحن نؤكد ان هذا تعبير عن حقيقه
ما يجول في خاطرهم وعن مخططاتهم التي
ينظرون او ينتظرون تنفيذها ولكننا نؤكد
كذلك انها لن تتحقق باذن الله فنحن اصحاب
الارض ونحن الباقون على هذا الارض وهم
الذين سيرحلون وما تردد في وسائل الاعلام
عن حراك دولي يقوده رئيس وزراء بريطاني
سابق من اجل تنفيذ هذا المخطط ورغم النفي
الذي صدر فان هذا يكشف عن تشبث بهذه
الفكره اننا نؤكد ان الذي سيغادر ارض
فلسطين وسيعود من حيث جاء هم المحتلون
وعلى سموتريتش ان يستعيد جنسيته
الاوكرانيه لانه ان نجى من القتل سيعود
الى هناك
قريبا ونؤكد ان ارضنا لن تكون الا ارضا
فلسطينيه للشعب الفلسطيني وحده وان شعبنا
الصامد المرابط ومقاومتنا الباسله هو ما
افشل مخطط التهجير ومخططات العدوان كامله
وهو ي تفتح بذلك صفحه جديده في نهايه هذا
الكيان باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى كما اننا
نؤكد ان كل ما يتردد من افكار حول انشاء
اداره مدنيه لقطاع غزه تعمل في ظل جيش
الاحتلال او باشراف امني عليه لن يكتب لها
الوجود ولا النجاح فقطاع غزه لن يكون الا
فلسطينيا خالصا ولن يقاد الا بفلسطيني وان
من يقرر قطا مستقبل فلسطين وارضها ونظامها
هو شعبها ولن تكون غزه الا جزءا اصيلا من
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله كامله السياده
عاصمتها القدس باذن
الله اما على صعيد المواقف الدوليه فاننا
نثمن ونقدر عاليا موقف د جنوب افريقيا
الصديقه في التضامن مع شعبنا وفي رفضها
للعدوان الصهيوني وكان اخر هذه المواقف
رفعها لدعوه قضائيه ضد الكيان الصهيوني
امام محكمه العدل الدوليه حول جرائم
الاحتلال ضد الانسانيه والتطهير العرقي
والاباده الجماعيه ولاول مره سيجلب هذا
الكيان صاغرا الى
لاهاي يوم الخميس القادم على طريق محاسبه
كل مجرمي هذا الكيان وكل النازيين في هذا
الكيان اننا ندعو جامعه الدول العربيه
ومنظمه التعاون الاسلامي والاتحاد
الافريقي الى دعم وتاييد موقف جنوب
افريقيا والى البناء عليه ورفع المزيد من
الدعاوى القضائيه في المحاكم الدوليه ضد
هذا الكيان مقاضاه له على جرائمه
بحق ابناء شعبنا ومنعا لافلا قادته من
العقاب
والمحاكمه اما على صعيد الاداره الامريكيه
فاننا نؤكد ان استمرار الاداره الامريكيه
في تزويد الكيان الصهيوني بالاسلحه
والمعدات العسكريه لاكثر من مره على
التوالي في ظل ما يرتكبه الاحتلال من
مجازر ضد المدنيين من ابناء شعبنا انما هو
تاكيد فعلي ليس فقط على الرعايه الكامله
لهذا العدوان وانما على الشراكه الكامله
في هذا العدوان ما يحمل هذه الاداره
واركانها المسؤوليه الاخلاقيه
والقانونيه والسياسيه على الشراكه الكامله
في سفك دم الشعب
الفلسطيني وفي الوقت الذي يقوم به الوزير
بلينكن بزياره للمنطقه فاننا
ندعو الاداره الامريكيه الى مراجعه شامله
وواقعيه للسياسات الامريكيه التي امتدت
على مدى شهور ثلاثه خلال هذا العدوان والى
مراجعه لموقفها تجاه ما يجري على ارض
فلسطين من انتهاكات ومجازر وحرب اباده كان
العامل الاساسيه في استمرارها هو الموقف
الامريكي الداعم لهذا الكيان ونؤكد كذلك
ان استمرار الاداره الامريكيه في التعاطي
مع المنطقه من منظور المصالح الصهيونيه
ومن منظور حمايه الكيان الصهيوني لن يدفع
ابدا لا الى امن ولا الى استقرار في
المنطقه وان كانت صادقه وجاده في تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه فان الخطوه
الاولى تبدا برفع الغطاء عن العدوان ال
اذا سنكتفي بهذا القدر من هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي للقيادي في حماس اسامه حمدان من
بيروت